In healthcare, large amounts of heterogeneous
medical data have become available in various
healthcare organizations.
This data could be an enabling resource for
deriving insights for improving care delivery
and reducing waste.
The enormity and complexity of these datasets
present great challenges in analyses and subsequent
applications to a practical clinical environment.
In this series of lectures, we will explore
the intersection of healthcare and big data.
At the end of this lecture, you should develop
understanding of healthcare data, the different
analytics algorithms, and understanding the
big data systems.
The healthcare industry is huge, and there
are a lot of data coming out of healthcare.
The United States healthcare is incredibly
expensive.
Overall spending is $3.8 trillion in U.S.
per year.
That’s more than the value of ten biggest
companies plus ten Beijing Olympics plus a
Warren Buffett, and a Bill Gates.
But does it have to be that way?
There is massive waste in healthcare unfortunately.
The estimated waste in U.S. healthcare alone
is $765 billion.
That’s equivalent to the NASA’s total
budget for the past 50 years.
Not only the cost is an issue, but also the
quality of healthcare is poor.
There are 200 to 400 thousand preventable
deaths per year in the U.S.
That’s 1,000 people per day.
If we classify the preventable deaths against
other causes of deaths, it will be the number
three causes of deaths in the United States,
after only heart disease and cancer.
So, there are massive problems presented in
modern healthcare, Including high costs, high
waste, and low quality.
How can big data help?
The hope is big data can lead to better care
and lower cost.
In big data, people talk about the four V’s:
Volume - Healthcare generates a large volume
of data.
For example, for genomic data each human genome
requires 200 gigabytes of raw data or 125
megabytes, if we store just SNPs.
For medical imaging data, a single MRI is
about 300 gigabytes.
Medical imaging data generated in the U.S.
per year was estimated to be 100 petabyte.
Variety - Healthcare also generates a lot
of different kind of information.
Such as clinical information, including patient’s
demographics, diagnosis, procedure, medication,
lab results, and the clinical notes.
Patient also generated a lot of data, such
as information coming out of arm body sensors
and other devices that patients wear.
Velocity - Healthcare also generate a lot
of real time data, such as blood pressure
measures, temperature, heart rate, drug dispensing
levels at intensive care units.
Veracity - Unfortunately, healthcare data
often comes with a lot of noise, a lot of
missing data, a lot of errors, and a lot of
false alarms.
It is a big challenge
in
healthcare
data analytics.